you'll hear today from Mike gianto who's
the president of the New York
firefighters Union you'll also hear from
Eddie Paulo who's the vice president he
grew up with firefighter akabu you'll
hear from Roger Terry who's the uncle of
Wayne Brooks Jr Michael Johnson who's a
firefighter
[Music]
yeah
Michael Johnson is with ladder four
and Captain Greg Meehan who's also with
ladder four when they come up I'll have
them introduce themselves and spell
their names for you as well
after each of them is done we'll have
time at the end to take questions
again we're starting about one minute
thank you for your patience this
afternoon
yellow
well they can't keep it on them
heard
[Music]
any online
thank you
anymore
foreign
good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming down my name is Michael Junta
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-g-i-u-n-t-a I'm the
president of Newark firefighters Union
I'm here to tell you that late Wednesday
night the Newark fire department
responded to one of the worst fires in
history
sadly two of our own firefighters
Augusto Augie
akabo and Wayne bear Brooks Jr
battling the fire
succumbed to their injuries
they were dedicated perfect servants
with combined 25 years for the Newark
Fire Department
there were colleagues our friends and
our brother
firefighting is a family
the aquaboo family and the Brooks family
are part of our family today and always
will be forever
line of duty that's affect each and
every one of us on a daily basis going
forward
we're not here today to talk about the
safety concerns
of the Newark Fire Department
at a later date we will discuss that
we're here to talk about our brothers
orgy and Bear
so we could remember them
going forward for the rest of our lives
there will be a time
that we will address
safety concerns
and the issues behind our brother's
deaths
but today
we have to focus on
our brother Auggie
and our brother
Wayne
so at the end we'll take any kind of
questions
but I want you to know that this Union
is focused on the families
and what they're going through right now
and with that I'd like to introduce my
vice president and personal friend that
grew up
with Augie
from a little child
Eddie Paolo
good afternoon everybody thank you for
coming out thank you uh as you can
imagine past 30 hours in this Newark
firefighter family has been horrific
everybody's uh
dealing with the grief everybody's
trying to get through this horrible time
[Music]
I'm the vice president and we're
firefighters Union my name is Eddie
Paulo EDD i-e-p-a-u-l-o
but today I'm not wearing that hat today
I'm wearing a
this press conference is to bring some
attention uh to let you guys know a
little bit about the Brooks uh family a
little bit about the acable family I'm
going to shed a little light on
my personal friend Augie both of them
were friends of mine but Augie was a
childhood friend of mine and uh I'd like
to take that mask off and just let you
know a little bit about him because the
media's got uh a job to do and trying to
find out as much as possible about uh
both the Fallen firefighters
um and I I can't help but to think about
I got a text message from somebody
saying
be what you love the most about who has
passed
when I started thinking about Augie I
think that's a that's that's almost
impossible because they don't make him
like him he was tough as nails and sweet
beyond belief Augie leaves behind
two brothers
Johnny
and Captain Michael akeable
of the Clark fired Police Department
he's behind two parents Mr Mrs Manuel
please behind
a sister-in-law Marley akabu
he leaves behind a nephew which he
adored James acable
Augie was all about the family all
really well you can find him at any
family cookout any family affair he
would do everything he can to attend
while he was an amazing friend
an amazing colleague and that guy that
walked away from any drama
that guy that uh brought a light to any
somber moment I could tell you right now
if he was sitting in the room
uh he'd be telling everybody to smile
everything's gonna be all right and
that's the kind of guy Augie was
you know in this profession you Google
the happiest jobs in the world and the
newer I'm sorry in the fire department
firefighting is going to be at the top
of the list and that's because of the
thing called Brotherhood and that
Brotherhood in Sisterhood that we've
been experiencing again uh tremendous
support
cause from across the country
from the
president
to
Police Department's fire departments in
New Jersey and across the country are
showing that Brotherhood showing that
support that has helped me and our
brothers and sisters uh keep going and
uh
at a later date we would go on with more
uh as to what happened but today we want
to share some information about the
academic family and the Brooks family
thank you that's who I got
introduce
Uncle Roger Terry who is the uncle of
firefighter Wayne Brooks Jr
thank you good afternoon and first of
all
my condolence to the akaboo family
it's a very difficult time I'm speaking
for
some of our family I understand that
Michelle
may be caught in traffic Wayne's wife
and is not here at this time
uh we were a real close family you know
many of my children
or the same age as Wayne
so I look at Wayne just not like my
nephew
but he's like my son
and it's been a very very difficult
day or so no one's had much sleep at all
and together as a family we've been
bounding and trying to make it through
this terrible time
Wayne
he wanted to be a firefighter
all of his life
he came out number one in his class his
firefighters he's tremendous athlete
also when he graduated from Saint
Benedict's High
he was one of the top fencers in the
state
he always kept himself in shape a real
life Superman you know the individual
cared about all kinds of people
he could have had any job that he wanted
in this region
but he picked being a firefighter
because he like
working with people and helping people
and uh
because of that you know we do know the
dangers
and uh unfortunately days lost his life
as a result of that
but I've heard it said that
greater had no man that lays his life
down for another so I know for a fact
that in heaven there's a special place
for him
our hearts are broken
but as I indicated as a family we'll
keep on moving on you know
for close-knit we'll work together and
we'll find a way in the next couple of
days weeks and months to get through
this please I ask everyone out there to
continue to pray
for the families of these two young men
we need a lot of prayer and uplifting
and thank you very much
Michael Johnson from ladder four
good afternoon everyone
my name is Michael Johnson
m-i-c-h-a-e-l j-o-h-n-s-o-n
um
I employ a lot of four crews
there was a
amazing person
great leader great friend great brother
left Australia
love the job
very horrific time
it's a very tough time for us
but we're gonna pull through
he's ever forgotten
it's in everybody's life
and his Department
amazing friend
amazing brother
excuse me points I can regain my bearing
he is a man's man
loved his wife
love his kids
he loved the job more than anything
we respect this fellow man respect the
fellow woman who came on his job
Wayne bear Brooks Junior you will never
be forgotten
most definitely
you'll always be a lot of foreign
thank you
Captain Greg Meehan also with ladder
four
hello
his name is Greg Meen capital letter
four Wayne was one of my guys
um
I could stand up here all day
talking about every good thing there is
about wings
start out he was
son or a wonderful family
which showed through and everything he
did with us at the firehouse
we cooked
we helped out
he was amazing understatement amazing
brother
husband
just in every regard number one guy
I know you're going to hear a lot of
things as to great smile never found a
without a smile
but uh
all I can say is
Mike Soto Tony the rest of our crew
his name will be on our minds for the
rest of our lives
there's no point where we're not gonna
remember bear
he was one of a kind
as far as Augie goes again
you're going to hear the time and time
again
upbeat
motivated
great great individual
they were just
taken from us too soon
thank you very much
this is Carlos Enriquez who is a cousin
of firefighter aquaboo
this is a statement from uh Augie's
family
Augie had a special way of reminding us
of his love whether it was his big hugs
before he left for work or simple I love
you
oh foggy always made sure we felt his
affection
and how great fit is difficult to
describe how deeply we love Auggie
he is our world and his untimely passing
has left an unfathomable unfathomable
absence in our home
Augie sense of Honor was unparalleled
and he consistently exemplified this
through his actions
everything he did was about helping
others going above and beyond for those
in need
saying a special bond with an assistant
football coach from high school who was
battling cancer and argue would often
run errands and provide support for him
during his treatments we only just
learned about that this week
those were the little things Augie did
for the people in his life it was just
the kind of person he was someone who
treated you like family
his infectious Spirit brought Joy
wherever he went
at Family parties he entertained all the
kids as a boxer he was over the moon
when he spotted Muhammad Ali and posed
for a photo together pretending to throw
a punch
Augie approached his work as a
firefighter like he approached
everything in life with dedication and
passion
his commitment to the job was unwavering
and his legacy will inspire those who
follow in his footsteps
this is who all he was
he would give you the shirt off his back
he was our hero
who we will miss every day and continue
to love forever
with that we have some time for
questions I'd ask if you could just
raise your hand then identify yourself
with your name and your outlet
happy to start
good afternoon again Michael Jordan to
the president of North firefighters
Union
first of all I'd like to thank all the
municipalities FDNY who came to help us
out you know Elizabeth fire department
we work hand in hand with other
municipalities
on a daily basis to get the jobs done
um as my vice president Eddie said
we had Governor Murphy visit us give us
a call we spoke to him personally
President Joe Biden gave us a call want
to know if we needed anything those that
that's the Outreach that we've had over
the last couple days and to help us
through this tragedy
so if you have any questions uh also I'm
sorry one one other thing we have a
GoFundMe page and uh we're trying to
help the families out and to see how
what we can do for them going forward
did you get any indication from the
president at the appropriate time that
he would visit the area that he would
visit your union or meet with the
families in response to this tragedy
yeah it's it's possible but it's not
confirmed right now
um he did make
an invitation to the families if they're
ever in Washington to come down yes he
did to show them the Oval Office
and the president called both families
as well
yeah
what's that a Stephen
called us yesterday he called us uh for
our Union and our fire department
um he uh extended his condolences gave
us a couple stories about his personal
stuff and then he called Michelle and
her family and also uh the mother and
father and the family of Augie and I was
President for them and uh I'll tell you
it just goes to show you how far this
extends across the country
bro
um I'm sure at one time in her career
because remember they had 25 years
combined
um so they have crossed each other's
paths absolutely because we worked in
the same sector uh you know in the fifth
Battalion here
anyone else
um yeah I mean uh there is there's
someone here that could take you down
there I mean I I don't know how close
you're going to get the Port Authority
has it all oh
emotionally what it was
you know
I don't you know what I'd rather focus
on the families and and what we were
going through right now rather than go
through the events of what happened at a
later date all is at you know all that's
going to be answered because like you
have questions I got a lot of questions
and I want answers okay so that's going
to happen in a later date but for right
now let's really focus on the families
and helping them get through things
there was just a big uh press conference
down at the Port where the uh the U.S
Coast Guard uh
you know talked about the the events and
what happened like that so let's leave
that up to them for right now and let's
all get uh help the families uh get get
through this
how many children did uh
Mr Brooks had two daughters yeah and uh
Olga didn't have any children
um dedicated son still lives in the same
house
you know with his mother and father and
his family they talked about how
dedicated he was to his family
New Jersey
heard that the services are indoors
right now I guess next week
what do you want to tell the folks in
New Jersey
you're watching this when these Services
happen
what should they take away from office
what they take away is we are public
servants you know we protect our
community
and we go to work every day
not knowing if we're coming home okay
and um
what I encourage them to do
is just pray for the families
you know and pray for some peace in
Newark right now you know what I mean
um
and just help us all move forward you
know just you know New Jersey needs to
help us
and as you can see behind me this is how
we we're strong together we have people
that flew in from Washington drove up
from Washington we have people here that
drove from Massachusetts flew from
Boston you know that's the outpouring
that we're getting and the support that
we're getting because we all need it
right now we're trying to stay as strong
as possible
sure
uh it's captain man g-r-e-g last name
m-e-e-h-a-n
car
h e n r i q u e s
you got a question there
um
yes all from the north fire department
have been released okay some minor
injuries but we do you know we did get a
couple guys injured I really can't speak
about the Elizabeth guys there was a
couple guys that went to the hospital I
hear they're doing a lot better so uh
that's all I have on the injuries
be able to share a personal story or
maybe I don't maybe at a later date
right now
um it's just too new okay and you know
we gave you this opportunity to try to
let them you know go through their
process you know
um and that's why we wanted to get the
word out about Augie you know and give
give the reporters what they need okay
can you also talk about despite the
risks of this job how rare the feeling
is
oh
it's not becoming so rare because we
have brothers all around this country
it's becoming
real raw for me
my experience when I first came on in
2000 I'm
24-year veteran and when I first came on
Lawrence Webb Jr was killed in a fire
and I was in the academy with his
brother
and we experienced that from day one
and that was that was a bad feeling you
know
today
is multiplied
um
this feeling I've never felt before in
my life
you know what we're going through
because I have 400 brothers and sisters
in this department and then the
outpouring and the Outreach that has
contacted me I just I'm overwhelmed with
the phone calls I can't even answer them
until 12 o'clock at night and I try to
do my best to text everybody back
you know
um
so it's getting hard it really is
getting hard but we're working through
it together
anyone know
the Union's doing to support the family
yeah also the I AFF Foundation is part
of that okay and um for corporations or
anybody would like to donate that way
um
we're supporting these families just by
being here
um there's an outpouring of people at
each house
um I've never seen anything like it
um you know just the Outreach and like
we said it goes as far as the president
you know and he assured us that you know
whatever support we need
you know um
so they're they're the GoFundMe pages of
the families of firefighter uh akabu and
firefighter Brooks
and um
we are forever
with their family
and I pledge to their daughters
to his daughters and his wife
and Augie's family that this is you have
all this support behind you no matter
what you need
we'll be here forever
anyone else
I think that concludes today and I'd
like to thank everybody for coming out
and sharing the Brooks family and the
aquaboo family I really appreciate
everything thank you
information next week certainly
regarding Services Also regarding some
of the questions and concerns that folks
have regarding Las Vegas incident we
appreciate your time I think many of you
have my contact information I have
business cards or other ways of getting
in touch with me if you need it please
thanks so much